[Music]
raspberry raspberry wait it doesn't it
doesn't look like an Oreo yeah what is
that this is not a conventionally shaped
Oreo this is a little turd it matches my
caste daddy thank you the cream is to
chalky to be created this texture would
go great with yogurt or ice cream tastes
like an Oreo made children's medicine
blueberry Oreo blueberry these are also
soft cookies soft cookies Oreos are not
soft there's a surprise waiting in the
middle for us so it's soft but what is
that blueberry rare cheese rare cheese
jelly fish this is like a diet cookie
with all the calories this is not an
order I feel like this is such a gentle
dessert they're not trying to overwhelm
me with any one ingredient oh [ __ ]
Garrett these are great better than when
like the hard Oreos crumble apart
because it's just like smells like a
mistake it kind of tastes like um coffee
Oreos I feel like I'm eating artisanal
Oreo I will say on the more I eat it the
more I'm like I could eat this forever
food best one I've had what is yummy
white chocolate they're so pretty yeah
this is one bite they're like Oreo
sticks people in Japan just like tiny
things yeah this smells like a
cheesecake ooh it's all right
I like the soft cookies better if this
were a lotion I'd rub it on my body
best things so far what Socrates I mean
okay here's the thing is that they're
not a bad cookie they're just not Oreos
my overall thought is that I'm happy to
be an American delicious and nutritious
certainly not either of those things I
love this this is like just the right
amount of sweetness I would rather eat
the normal
American or yes than any of these I want
to go to Japan you want to go to Japan
do buddy trip to Japan love yourself
where you love yourself you're beautiful
just the way you are I'm using
chopsticks in honor of Chaplin oh I want
to use chopsticks I brought them from
home he's here yeah I brought them to
make this this guy